hi everyone again and now we have monty
teaching uh uh monty and if i didn't
pronounce your name uh right please
correct me uh to talk about what could
possibly go wrong with iran when
evaluating forecasts uh monty um
after uh he
uh
joined blue yoda as a data scientist in
2015
and he has worked on numerous external
and internal projects uh which all and
all of them kind of involved uh in uh
programming python development
predictions and communicating the
achieved results so um and monty and we
can snap out thank you
yeah thank you howard
yeah my name is malta i joined blue
yonder in 2015 and one of the first
questions i asked was of course what
could possibly go wrong when evaluating
forecasts
now six years later i can hopefully give
you partially an answer to that
so forecasts can concern continuous
quantities like the temperature of
tomorrow or the blood pressure
but they can also concern discrete
categories like will that email be
marked as spam is that animal a cat or
dog
in supply chain
what we're dealing with we often have a
hybrid case because we have discrete
quantities of countable atomic objects
just like t-shirts
so this is a quantity because zero
smaller than one is smaller than two and
so on but it's also discrete because we
don't have two and a half t-shirts or
3.7 t-shirts that we could sell
and this combination that we have a
discrete one discrete quantity is
actually uh offering us quite some
challenges
so let's set up the stage that we're
working in let's assume we are a data
scientist and our task is to predict
t-shirt sales in time
we are given this data set here the
t-shirt sales in the past we are
training a model
and we are then extrapolating um our
prediction to the future to make a
forecast how many t-shirts will be sold
the future will eventually dribble in
and we have the actual out of sample
sales and management will come at some
stage and ask how good is that forecast
now how good is the forecast is a really
hard question and we like to substitute
it
with a much clearer question it is much
better to confine for example what's the
forecast's mean absolute error here we
plug in the observations that we have we
plug in the predictions and we get a
number and we can give that number to
management
but management won't be happy with that
they want to know what does it mean is
this now good or is this bad
and we'll see that coming from that
expression here to a judgment of a
forecast is a really long journey
in the first place we have to interpret
our forecast wisely because forecasts
trivially are not observations and it's
not even so clear what number to plug in
here as a prediction
in the second place we will have to
manage expectations
we have to have a different expectation
for the
slow sellers that sell maybe once or
twice a day than from the fast sellers
that sell 100 times a day so we cannot
compare the slow sellers to the fast
sellers and i'll show you why
finally there are many things that can
go wrong when when grouping data and you
might fall into the hindsight paradox
where you think you should have known
better but it turns out you shouldn't
so let's start by interpreting the
forecast wisely
management might come to you and they
might ask what do you mean by tomorrow
red t-shirt sales will be 9.47
do you really mean we will sell nine
t-shirts and then somebody will buy half
a t-shirt well obviously not this
statement here is a probabilistic
statement that reveals our belief about
the mean sales that will occur on days
like tomorrow where we predict 9.47
and what is not in this statement here
but somewhere implicit is we probably
have done personal regression or some
kind of regression that takes into
account that we have a discrete quantity
and there's a probability distribution
behind the seams
now that probability distribution
becomes important
when we want to evaluate mean absolute
error where we subtract from each
observation our prediction
because the observation is pretty clear
what we want to plug in say we observe
seven t-shirts well then we just plug in
the number seven
but this here that's not a number that's
a function and if we want to
summarize a function we have to do this
in a certain way and it's not not clear
a priori how we would summarize a
distribution to plug in here
and this summary is also called a point
estimator and this problem to find the
correct point estimated plug in uh into
a metric that's very generic that will
um yeah occur for every evaluation
metric
now
for this concrete case let's assume we
have to put some distribution rate at
9.47 so we have one forecasted
distribution and it turns out
that the point estimator for mean
absolute error is the median of the
distribution so the correct number to
go into this prediction k here um when
you when we evaluate mean absolute error
is the median so the number that divides
the probability distribution into equal
halves
if you evaluate mean squared error then
the correct point estimator turns out to
be the mean of the distribution so the
most popular summary statistic and the
number that you would use is 9.47
if you use a more exotic and actually
quite dangerous
evaluation metric like mean absolute
percentage error
the number that you have to plug in here
is sometimes called the minus one median
i don't have an intuit intuitive way to
explain this but it's well it's the
number k that solves this equation um as
well as possible
and now for this particular example with
that distribution here the minus one
median turns out to be eight so for
maple our uh prediction would be eight
for the mean absolute error the median
that we plug in here is nine and the
means 9.47 so for me squared error we
would use 9.47
okay now you might ask well these
numbers are different but they're not so
different could we just always summarize
distributions by their mean i mean the
mean is the most popular the most
intuitive summary of a distribution
well we could do that this is what you
would get here you have as a function of
the true rate the bias that you will
have in your estimated rate if you used
a naive map estimator or naive mae
estimator and don't do this
differentiation between mean and median
so for mae you will heavily
underestimate the slow movers because
you will predict zero
essentially everywhere whenever the
the
article is selling more slowly than 0.7
times a day and you will be quite
inaccurate on the mid movers
for maper you will heavily overestimate
the slow movers because the lowest
prediction that makes sense for mabel is
one
and you will underestimate the mid to
far fast movers now note this is all in
the lab this is all in an idealized case
so the answer is clearly no because the
best model that you will get will be
biased and quite inaccurate
now think about it if we have a
procedure that doesn't even work um in
the lab in a totally idealized
environment what could then happen if
you're out there in the real world where
you have many more problems
to deal with
so so far we assumed a poisson
distribution and i didn't really
substantiate why that is a good choice
and you might also say well you know i
understand the concept of uncertainty i
know what uncertainty is but i don't
want uncertainty i want a deterministic
forecast if the forecast is five the
mean is five i want the number of soul
t-shirts to be exactly five not four not
six and then all these summaries will be
the same number
yeah let's see what that actually means
to have such an um
requirement on a forecast
express is a probability distribution we
have this figure here the probability to
have five sales is one the probability
to have four sales or six sales or eight
or so is just zero
so what does it mean about the degree of
information that we have about our
customers well that means we know five
customers of which we can say with
certainty they will definitely buy a red
t-shirt tomorrow
but not only is this a very strong
statement about these five customers i
mean who is ever so sure to buy a
t-shirt on the next day but it's also a
really strong statement about all the
other customers because because we can
absolutely exclude that nobody of them
might spontaneously buy to buy a red
t-shirt
so this degree of certainty is
unreachable if you have a product-based
forecast and already if you weaken the
assumption a little bit so you say you
have six customers and each of them has
a probability of 83 percent to buy the
article you get this binomial
distribution here which is immediately
much
wider the probability to observe exactly
five goes down to forty percent
now you can can move on you can think of
ten customers with probably fifty
percent each this might just be the
situation if you have a really small
bakery in a really small village with
very few customers and each customer has
a really high chance to
to come and buy by bread in your bakery
then you have this distribution
like that
but typically for retailers
we don't even know how many customers
will come on a given day
and we'll have to use the poisson limit
that is we somehow have many many
customers and we have an estimate of
what's the average probability for a
customer to to buy the product
so that is somehow the standard
benchmark for integer predictions under
certain assumptions like many potential
customers each customer has a very small
probability to buy an item on average
and nobody buys two or more items
the poisson distribution is
parameterized by exactly one parameter
that's the rate and the rate also
coincides with the mean of the
distribution that's that's very
convenient
that is the poisson distribution for a
rate of one for rate of four and a rate
of twelve
now we can plug the pieces together we
can now ask what is the achievable
relative mean absolute error under the
personal distribution so assuming we are
correct assuming our forecast is perfect
and the true sales are really
distributed according to poisson
distribution what is the mean absolute
error or relative mean absolute error
that we will reach because this is a
lower bound to what we can
promise to anyone to for example to
management and that's really easy to do
in python i mean you just import the
poisson distribution from scipy studs
let's generate a large array of
possible poisson rates between 0 and 15
and for each of these rates we draw 10
thousand observations that we randomly
draw from the poisson distribution
so we have a big rectangular array here
and we can then compute the achieved
mean absolute error so we take the mean
over the absolute
difference between the median of the
rates we've just seen that the correct
point estimator for i mean absolute
error is the median and we subtract the
observations and we have to choose the
correct axis to do our mean
and if you do that you will
get some numerical results there are
also some analytical formulas that you
can find in this paper and you'll get a
plot like that one so as a function of
the poisson rate as a function of our
predicted rate this is the mean absolute
error that we can expect in the
idealized case
so if the prediction is 5 we have to
live with a mean absolute error of 1.75
and if the prediction is 10 we have to
live with a mean absolute error of 2.5
now obviously this curve is increasing
and sometimes
what people do is they try to normalize
the scaling effect away by just dividing
by the mean observation but this doesn't
work
because then you get an inverse scaling
effect in the relative mean absolute
arrow that is the mean absolute error
divided by the mean observation
um you have to yeah you just see that
you have to live with high values
for the slow sellers and only if your
prediction is large enough you can
expect the relative mean absolute error
to to be lower than than a certain value
now when we um
show some scores of what we achieve for
different products we should always show
them together with benchmarks now think
we have different assortments we have
the dresses we have the socks we have
the t-shirts and we reach a certain
relative mean absolute arrow that is
0.76 for t-shirts and there's 3.55 for
socks and somewhere in between for the
dresses if you only see these bars here
your conclusion would be well the socks
are doing best and the t-shirts are
doing worst
but we just saw that what you can
achieve depends on the
prediction itself so you should include
the poisson benchmark the best possible
that you can ever have and now the
conclusion is very different because you
see that for socks there's a huge
potential that could in principle reach
a relative mean absolute error of only
six percent so there's a lot to gain
here while the t-shirts are already
close to what is possible in principle
so but why are slow sellers
different so much from fast sellers
because it turns out that few is really
different
in the first place it's much harder to
learn from slow solid
than from fast sellers how much do we
learn about the product by observing it
on one day let's assume it's a red
t-shirt and the red t-shirt didn't sell
at all nobody wanted to buy that red
t-shirt what can we say at the end of
that day
well this blue curve here is the
posterior distribution of our belief of
the rate of sale of the t-shirt after
having measured a zero
so we have measured zero the most
probable value is that nobody ever wants
to buy the t-shirt but there's still a
finite probability
density that
i have a rate of sale of maybe one and i
was a little bit unlucky because nobody
happened to buy the t-shirt maybe i even
have a rate of sale of three and i was
very unlucky that nobody bought the
t-shirt but so relatively speaking
there's quite little that i can say
about the true rate of sale it could be
zero it could be 0.1 or one or maybe
even four and we have a strong
dependence on our prior belief so do i
believe that t-shirts typically sell
once a day or do they typically sell 10
times a day
this is very different for fast sellers
i mean consider blue socks everybody
likes blue socks so they sell a thousand
times on the first day we observe them
this is the posterior probability
distribution for the rate which is very
peaked around a rate of 1000 so you can
be absolutely sure that the true rate is
between say 800 and 1200 it doesn't
really matter whether you thought
blue blue stocks are popular or not they
sold a thousand times you can be sure
that um the true rate is uh
close to one thousand
so we have a phenomenon here that the
quantity of interest the rate of sale
that we want to learn actually
determines itself how fast we can learn
about it and this is why we are learning
much less from the from slow sellers
than from the fast sellers
but even if we have learned everything
about the slow server say now we have
observed a red t-shirt for many many
years we know on average cells once a
day
then a poisson distribution reveals
quite little about what will happen on a
given day
so that's again the poisson distribution
for a rate of one and i have also drawn
the binomial distribution for n equal 10
as a comparison so you think uh you can
think about this you have like 10
customers and each of them has a
probability of 10 percent
to buy a red t-shirt
now it's quite likely or
not unlikely that nobody buys any
t-shirt you have zero sales and zero is
100 off relatively speaking from one so
i have a huge probability to be
very off i also have a huge probability
to be more than plus 100 off because
maybe out of these 10 customers you have
two that would like to buy a t-shirt or
even three it's not
so unlikely
this is very different from popular
dress that sells 20 times a day
i mean here the probability to sell zero
dresses is negligible and so is the
probability to sell more than 40 dresses
you can think about this like having 40
customers and each of them have a
probability of fifty percent
uh to buy the dress so you can be sure
the total number of sold dresses will be
around 15 to 25 or so and that's
relatively speaking quite close to 20.
so this explains why if we draw the best
possible achievable relative mean
absolute error as a function of the
predicted rate we have this particular
shape here
that
goes down as we increase the rate so for
rate one we have to live with um a
relative mean absolute error of more
than seventy percent for rate of four we
have still to live with about forty
percent and then only if the rate is
about one hundred we can expect the
relative mean absolute error in the
ideal case to be lower than 10
we also see there is an unachievable
region so if management comes and says
for the slow sellers that's around once
a day we want um a relative mean
absolute error of 40 that would be that
point here the answer is simply that's
impossible if you have
a poisson distributed
quantity
and when you judge how well um the
forecast is doing you shouldn't measure
the distance from the bottom here from
the zero line but somehow the distance
from that red line and so you would
judge the smallest like i insinuated
here with these colors
so by now you have hopefully um
convinced management that forecast
precision will be worse for those low
sellers but then they come with an
evaluation
and they tell you well but you're under
forecast the fast sellers and you over
forecast the slow sellers there's a big
problem
well you will ask for the data and it
will give you this table here
so by the observed sales frequency slow
medium and fast they have aggregated the
mean observed sales to be 0.8 5.1 or
13.88 and the mean predicted rate in the
same bucket which is 1.37 4.6 or 11.0
and obviously that number is larger than
this one let's assume it's statistically
significant so we had we have had many
many days and many many sales and that
number is much smaller than this number
here
and you will go and you will do an
analysis and you will come back to
management and say that's totally fine
that's okay and that's expected
well you'll probably have to corroborate
that statement a little bit and i'll
give you three arguments why that is the
case the first one will be based on bias
rule the expectation that we are having
from that table that these numbers
should match is simply wrong we
shouldn't expect this to be the case we
just can't expect it
the second argument
is just a numerical experiment you can
very easily reproduce this effect with a
few lines of python code and the third
argument would be evaluation hygiene we
are committing a really bad sin here in
the evaluation and we'll see which one
it is
so let's start with arguing via buys
rule
so what do we actually get from our
prediction our prediction is a statement
about how the sales will be distributed
if we issue a certain rate
as our prediction
and yeah i just wrote down the poisson
distribution uh you can now compute the
expectation value of the sales
provided a certain rate you can plug in
these numbers and you find it coincides
with the rate so given a sales forecast
given a rate
the mean observed sales they should
approach the predicted rate in the
statistical limit this is what the
forecast is promising you
now on that table we didn't bucket by
rate we didn't bucket by forecast but we
bucketed by actual we bucketed by the
actual sales so what we're interested in
is not this conditional probability here
sales given rate but we are interested
in the rate given the sales so what
should we have predicted
given a certain sales number now bias
rule tells us that these two quantities
are related um they're proportional but
we have these two probabilities here
um that that will correct that
now if we had a deterministic forecast
then um p of rate and p of sales would
be the same and they would just cancel
out and everything would be fine but we
have a probabilistic forecast so
this will in general
not be the same
you can compute the expectation value of
the rate
given the sales so what should we have
predicted on average
given a certain sale that's an integral
here that can be solved analytically for
some edge cases or numerically it's
actually not not a big problem and you
find that for probabilistic forecasts in
the vast majority of cases
this expectation value does not become
the sales value so given a certain
observed sales value we cannot expect
that our mean predicted rate would match
that sales
value
this is simply not something that's in
the box when you when you get a forecast
the easiest way to see why that has to
be the case is consider the sales of
zero so you pick all the days when the
t-shirt was sold zero times there will
definitely be days where you have
predicted the t-shirt to be sold maybe
half a time or once um and you were just
a little bit unlucky
uh that it never sold so we are somehow
post-selecting the bad luck um
[Music]
events so our uh rate that we will have
predicted for these zero sales is on
average definitely larger than zero
because we've never
uh predicted some negative rate
okay now we have a
um a slide here with lots of formulas
maybe your management can be convinced
by that but maybe it can't and then you
can maybe do this numerical experiment
here
so let's simulate this situation uh by
brute force let's generate lots of
random rates pick them out of the gamma
distribution
and let's draw observations again from a
poisson distribution from from these
random rates so the the rates are
distributed like this here we have a
histogram and we can then define the
masks just as they have been defined for
this table we have the mask for the slow
sellers for the mid sellers for the fast
sellers and we mask on the actually
drawn observations
so here we have a histogram of the
observed sales when the slow sellers the
net sellers and the fast sellers
and we can now reproduce what we have
seen in the table for each of these
masks we compute the mean predicted rate
and the mean observed sales and you see
that these numbers exactly match so this
apparent over prediction of slow sellers
and under prediction of fast sellers is
reproduced one by one by an idealized
numerical lab experiment so it cannot be
considered a flaw i mean this is all
idealized i mean the personal
distribution from sci-fi starts works
so
and
this is not something that is
broken
in in the forecast but it's something
that's broken in the evaluation
now what what's the the problem here in
the evaluation now we have grouped the
results by the actually observed sales
but this is a criterion that is exposed
that was unknown at the moment of um the
forecast
so and this is very inadmissible very
much in general this is the very
hindsight paradox that you knew better
what would happen and you're using
future information to group the
predictions and observations
so you can really say that you should
not have known better if you're using
something for the evaluation that was
not known at the moment of the
prediction
yeah hopefully you convinced manage but
by then they will they will want some uh
some solution how shall we then evaluate
and it's quite easy don't group by the
outcome but group by prediction then you
get a
table like this one we again have the
slow sellers the medium sellers and the
fast sellers but the predicted slow
sellers medium sellers and fast sellers
and now the mean observed sales and mean
predicted sales will not differ
statistically significantly
if your model is correct
so and this is past information this is
what you know at the moment of the
prediction you can already define the
buckets and see uh yeah whether where
the sales will fall in
um yeah when you do this in python it's
very similar to what we saw before but
we now have a mask that applies to the
rates and not to the actual outcomes and
here all the
numbers match quite quite nicely
and this is exactly what a forecast is
promising you that the expectation value
of the sales given a rate will approach
the rate
so we went on quite a long journey from
what's the forecast mean absolute error
to how to judge a forecast and how to
see is a forecast a good forecast or a
bad forecast
let me make one more point here how good
is the forecast is just a special case
of a much more general question how good
is technology x
because every technology is constrained
by logical physical bounds i mean think
if you are not if you were not a data
scientist but a rocket scientist
you cannot just have any possible
trajectory of a rocket because you are
constrained by classical mechanics i
mean there are simply things that are
impossible in rocket science
if you put solar cells onto your roof
or you run the power plant
thermodynamics will put an upper bound
on the efficiency that you can achieve
and i mean you can try to argue against
nature but it won't work and very much
like this
we are now here talking about
information technology and that
technology is also bound and counting
statistics will bind the precision of
what forecasts forecasted can be
achieved and this should be taken into
account when that forecast is evaluated
so we saw three different things that
can go wrong when evaluating forecasts
of course there are many more
and the very general advice that they
can give is a very old-fashioned one not
very their original just test
don't rely on what you hope your
evaluation will achieve i mean you don't
rely on what you hope your code will
achieve either but you have right tests
and don't test it just uh technically
that if you plug the numbers in you get
numbers out but test it functionally so
build controlled cases of what could
happen use the ideal case um use a bias
case say you're 10 off you're 20 30 off
what would uh that evaluation tell you
use some noisier or more imprecise um
observations um instead of the ideal
ones add some outliers use a different
distribution and see how that evaluation
pipeline will behave in whether it's
giving the right answers because for
these test cases you know the right
answers and when you then understand
your evaluation in this lab-like
environment you can also expect it to
work out there in the field and to draw
the correct conclusions about which
model is better
and which one then to choose in
production
yeah i hope you enjoyed this talk
if you have questions comments i think
we have a little bit of time left and
otherwise we can have a discussion on
the talks channel on slack thank you
very much
um thanks monkey so we have two
questions uh at the moment at the
clinton a session the first question is
related to
a slow mover forecast
uh
semi best asks so can we say that it is
hard to forecast individual slow mover
forecasts because of data or
vaporization distribution
exactly that's how i would phrase it
like the best that i can expect when i
predict a product to be sold is
in many cases the poisson distribution
so the best i will get is a poisson
distribution and here i just have to
live with a certain level of relative
mean absolute error and that level will
be higher than for a fast seller
um so i would yeah i i would agree with
that with that statement
okay and i think this uh christine has
one more question uh how do you scale
this analysis and we tell us have
usually more than two products yeah yeah
so the retailers that i work with they
have ten thousands of products of course
yeah so i for simplicity i just only
talked about red t-shirts yeah in in
practice you will have the dimension of
time so you have one t-shirt in time and
you want to predict how that is changing
in time and in addition you will have
the product dimension on a given day you
have maybe 100 000 different products
and you will um have to to judge how
these products are doing but the general
um yeah statistical behavior of your
forecast you can just aggregate over the
product so you can also pick all the
products that you
predicted to sell about uh five times
today and see how are the real sales
distributed across these products
because once you find maybe some
some buyers you want to know is this um
yeah a product dependent bias are you
maybe over forecasting all the t-shirts
and they're forecasting uh the
vegetables um yeah but you can
yeah i was focusing on the on the
statistical part uh the individual
predictions and observations that will
enter they can also come from different
products from uh different locations um
etc
thanks monty so uh
now let's move on to the next
presentation thank you very much again
yeah thanks